and I looked at it and I thought wow
this is this is a federal grand jury
subpoena to a recent magazine you may
have heard about the scary situation
reason.com was recently in the US
Justice Department sent a grand jury
subpoena and letter to reason commanding
editors to hand over the records of six
anonymous commenters who wrote
hyperbolic statements about federal
judge Katherine Forrest she's the judge
who sentenced Ross Ulbricht or Dread
Pirate Roberts to life in prison without
parole for creating the Silk Road
website and to make matters worse the
DOJ later requested a gag order from the
US District Court which they got meaning
reason couldn't write or speak publicly
about what was going on but even so the
story still leaked I got an email and I
looked at it and I thought wow this is a
federal grand jury subpoena to a recent
magazine for commenter data to identify
people who are anonymously comment
that's ken white a former federal
prosecutor and writer at the legal blog
Pope add he was the one who was able to
break the story oh so you didn't even
know who this person was or is I did not
I just looked enough to figure out it
didn't appear to be from anyone a reason
do you know now I don't know for certain
but all the indications to me suggests a
commenter and so white contacted
everyone involved to try and figure out
what happened first I emailed reason I
reached out to Nicholas B and asked if I
could get a comment he said no so armed
with that I called the assistant US
attorney and asked him if he could
comment and I told him that I was going
to run a story about the subpoena unless
he could convince me that there was some
actual danger to life involved here so I
succeeded in getting him to say things
like well how can we know whether these
people are real danger until we
investigated them and we have to
investigate everyone and that satisfied
me there was no secret evidence that
these people were you know out with a
bomb or something like that and I got a
little pushback a little threat we're
going to have to look into how you got
this so forth and so that convinced me
all right this is a story I'm going to
write after the assistant US attorney
talked to reasons lawyer and found out
that reason was planning on informing
the commenters look the subpoena came in
if you want to stop it
that's in your court
you know we can't once he found that out
he immediately went to the judge and
asked for a gag order under this
internet provision usually federal grand
jury subpoenas don't carry a gag order
now they will carry a scary letter to
you if you get one saying there's no
legal prohibition on you telling people
about this but if you do I just want to
let you know that we United States
Department of Justice might conclude
that you're interfering with a federal
grand jury investigation what's
upsetting is that there's no indication
whatsoever either that the prosecutor or
the judge gave any consideration to the
fact that this was being aimed at a
reporting organization about a First
Amendment issue White's story raised
serious questions about press freedom
and open expression online and it was
all over comments like its judges like
these that should be taken out back and
shot as well as shoot them out front on
the steps of the courthouse and of
course why waste ammunition wood
chippers get the message across clearly
especially if you feed them in
feet-first a reference to the
oscar-winning movie Fargo and these
statements they're hyperbolic statements
they're perhaps juvenile statements but
they're pretty par for the course for
the internet and really reason.com
can you talk about that for us
absolutely some of them I would
characterize is mild by internet
standards and certainly by recent
standards I mean one of them says I hope
there's a hot place in hell for the
judge who gave this guide the life
sentence now there's no by no stretch of
the imagination is that a threat if it
is then 50% of what's written on the
Internet is a threat and you know
forty-nine percent is porn so the
commenter does not have the power to
consign the judge to hell presuming that
the commenter is God which I sincerely
hope the US Attorney's Office was
ostensibly looking for evidence of a
true threat can you define a true threat
under the law for us sure some threats
like you know I to go punch Donald Trump
and the know something like that are not
true threats are protected by the First
Amendment because no one would interpret
them to be real a true threat is a
threat that's outside the protection of
the First Amendment and the core of it
is
that it has to be something that
objectively a reasonable person looking
at the threat and familiar with the
context of the threat would think was a
sincere expression of an intent to do
harm
now there's also an issue now of what
subjective intent there has to be to
convict you and that was before the
Supreme Court this term they punted they
didn't clarify it completely but what
they did indicate is that there is also
a subjective element it's pretty clear
that either you have to intend that your
words be taken for real and tend that
people think you really mean to harm
somebody or at least you have to be
reckless about it but white says well
that may be the law that doesn't stop
federal prosecutors from sending out
subpoenas trying to dig up info wherever
they can the US Attorney's Office
position seems to be well we're entitled
to find out we don't have to have a case
that we can win on at time we send a
grand jury subpoena and unfortunately
they have loss according so there was a
case in Washington DC this was during
the 2012 presidential election Michelle
Bachmann was a candidate for the
Republican nomination somewhat colorful
one and there was a colorful character
on Twitter who said something effective
you know something horrible should
happen to Michelle Bachman with a
vietnam-era machete I don't remember the
details but it was gross any rational
person moderately familiar with Twitter
or with American discourse would say
okay that's someone blowing off steam
that so I'm playing a character but the
government subpoenaed Twitter to get the
person's identity and what the judge
rather disappointingly said was well
it's clearly not a true threat we think
it's clear you couldn't charge someone
based on this it would be dismissed if
you did you couldn't convict them it
would be overturned if you did but the
government's interest in seeing whether
or not there are real threats out there
justify doing this to try to get this
person's identity so the judge sort of
built up the American value of anonymity
and the First Amendment only to say that
the government's alleged interest in
finding people who are below VA ting
justifies piercing that do you think the
reason was targeted I don't think so in
other words I don't think that
the US attorney in New York or the
assistant US attorney thought I hate
libertarians I particularly hate mouthy
libertarians I'm going to strike my blow
by sending the subpoena to reason that's
pretty much who we are as mouthy
libertarians well I think I saw it on
the door when I came out um the more
likely it's just like you know fish
doesn't know that it's in a water
federal prosecutor doesn't know they're
swimming in power they could do it so
they did there's no particular reason
for them not to because there's really
no consequences most of the time when
they violate rights or break the law so
why not do it White says the what we're
really talking about here is the power
of government a federal prosecutor has a
really enormous amount of power over
human lives not just by taking a case to
trial and getting someone convicted
inside the federal prison but just by
musing the mechanism of the federal
criminal justice system sending a grand
jury subpoena to someone telling someone
they're under investigation these are
all life-changing things potentially and
being under investigation is something
if you hire lawyers and defend
yourselves it could cost you every penny
you have and what I saw as a federal
prosecutor was that it was very easy to
wield those powers without really
reflecting on the fact that you're
wielding them and this is power very
often given to quite young people the
most significant takeaway that comes
from what happened to reason in these
six commenters may be how open
expression of any stripe will be
perceived online does it present a
chilling effect I mean for people that
want to use the Internet I think it does
and unfortunately I think it's more
likely to chill the people who are
reflective about what they say them the
people who aren't I think people who
have a tendency to talk about wood
chippers are going to keep talking about
wood chippers pretty much the same but I
think responsible people who care about
what they're talking about are always
going to be reflecting you know should I
use that analogy should I use that
metaphor is this a time for that purple
prose can I make the Shakespeare comment
about killing all the lawyers you know
can I make that cultural TV movie
internet mean run
or is some person somewhere going to get
upset and I think people are going to
perceive correctly that the time when
they're most likely to run into trouble
is when they're commenting about the
powerful when they're commenting about
judges politicians people with real
power because those are the ones who can
pick up the phone and get an assistant
United States attorney to issue a
federal grand jury subpoena you have any
tips for reasoned calm commenters well I
hear there's a sail on wood chippers a
Tosh beyond that I would say there's
what you can do and what you should do I
absolutely believe in vigorously
expressing yourself
I believe in criticizing harshly the
federal government when it does things
like carrying out a a moral and ruinous
war on drugs but on the other hand I
think that people could have been a lot
more convincing on the topic of how
frankly evil that sentence was than by
talking about shooting people are
putting in the wood chippers frankly
shooting people seems to be more the
government thing